[Música]
y nuevamente hablamos de economía que en
directo américa de france24 de mendes en
el estudio louis vamos a comenzar en
venezuela porque quedó todo en suspenso
la oferta de las sanciones de empresas
públicas en ese país así es raúl por lo
menos así se desprende de diversos
medios de comunicación de ese país entre
ellos también destaca la noticia la
agencia efe y sustenta en el comentario
en el cierre de la bolsa de valores de
caracas del 16 de mayo de manera no
oficial se espera un crecimiento de
entre 5 y 8 por ciento en el producto
interno bruto de esa nación para este
año según la agencia de noticias
española tras varios años de caídas
económicas desde el año 2013 pero de
acuerdo con la institución financiera en
este caso una bolsa de valores de
caracas al cierre de la jornada de el
pasado día lunes no recibieron
comunicación relacionada con el anuncio
que había hecho el presidente nicolás
maduro adicionalmente en las últimas
publicaciones del cierre de la
institución tanto del viernes 13 de mayo
como del lunes 16 no se observan
variaciones
al número de empresas que cotizan en la
bolsa recordemos que son 22 las empresas
que cotizan en esta bolsa y la única
pública presente es cantv privatizada en
1991 y nacionalizada en 2007 vale
recordar que nicolás maduro anunció que
ofertaría un paquete accionario de entre
5 y 10 por ciento de varias empresas
públicas entre ellas petroleras mineras
y de telecomunicaciones de esto como
parte de un plan para buscar recursos y
modernizar a muchas de estas empresas y
espero que ha dicho entonces el gobierno
venezolano respecto una posible fecha
para así ofertar las acciones de estas
empresas públicas raúl por el momento no
han dado razones por las cuales ayer no
se lleva a cabo esta operación y tampoco
han anunciado para cuando podría
llevarse a cabo esta salida a bolsa pero
lo que sí dejó claro es que cuenta con
inversionistas interesados en aplicar
este proceso pero no ofreció mayores
detalles escuchemos
las expectativas de inversión son
gigantescas
centenares de inversionistas listos para
entrarle
a invertir en las acciones del paquete
accionario entre el 5 al 10 por ciento
que ya está hecha de ingeniería para
colocarlos en las bolsas de valor
centenares
toma nota
claro los centrales interesados pero si
uno ve no obviamente la seguridad
jurídica y la seriedad en este caso en
versión porque tampoco es que uno va en
versionar va a hacer esa inversión por
un dólar pues es como hacerlo no cuando
se dijo que el lunes y pues hasta ahora
no se sabe cuándo va a ser vamos a
hablar ahora seguimos hablando de
empresas veces porque un anuncio de los
mossos genera caídas en el precio de la
acción de twitter así es raúl y es que
un mensaje publicado muy temprano por el
multimillonario de origen sudafricano
confirmó la intención de mantener la
suspensión de la oferta realizada para
adquirir la totalidad de la compañía en
su mensaje mos que ha tenido diferencias
tanto con el sello de la compañía como
con algunos de los ejecutivos o por el
caso de las cuentas falsas pide
demostrar que éstas representan menos
del 5 por ciento del universo de
usuarios de la empresa en su mensaje en
mod indica que su propuesta se basó en
los informes de twitter ante la sec el
organismo regulador y que estos son
precisos pero ante la negativa de la
empresa de no mostrar pruebas el acuerdo
no podría avanzar a finales de la
segunda semana de mayo generó
inestabilidad en los precios por acción
de la compañía ya que mantuvo o anunció
una suspensión temporal de la oferta
inicial de acuerdo con la agencia de
noticias reuters la empresa ha
manifestado su compromiso para cumplir
el trato al precio y los términos que
fueron acordados para shamaa sobre
europa porque se dieron a conocer los
datos dlp y de trimestral louis así es
específicamente en la zona euro el
indicador registró un aumento de 0 3% o
en este caso puntos porcentuales en el
período 2000 lo comparamos con el cuarto
trimestre del año pasado en cuanto a la
unión europe en su totalidad ésta se
situó en 0.4 puntos porcentuales esto es
una décima menos que el último período
del año 2021 en comparación con el
primer trimestre de 2021 el pib de la
zona euro o de aquellos países que
asumieron el euro como moneda creció 5,1
por ciento 4 puntos porcentuales
respecto al alza interanual de los
últimos tres meses del año
así es vida argentina y brasil se
perfilan como posibles proveedores de
aceite comestible no hay que señalar que
india es un alto consumidor de este
producto y de acuerdo con la publicación
qatarí al yazira un 90 por ciento de las
importaciones de aceite de girasol
proceden de ucrania pero debido a la
guerra estas se han detenido y de hecho
el blog es anti global proyecto en
noviembre de 2021 que india recibiría
alrededor de 2,4 millones de toneladas
de este producto para el período 2021
2022 desde un estimado de 1.88 millones
pero la guerra ha obligado a india a
cambiar su patrón de consumo y a buscar
nuevas fuentes de aceites comestibles
que creció igual de lyon es ya prohibió
la exportación de aceite de palma y por
ello apuntan a argentina y brasil con el
aceite de soya pero para suplir esta
falta ambos países deben solventar
algunos problemas entre ellos las
sequías
louis rápidamente cifra el día tiene que
ver en este caso con los 21 mil millones
de dólares que fue fijado en el
presupuesto para el año fiscal de japón
2022 graciasluis como siempre por toda
la información de economía nos vemos
mañana con más directo hasta parís